has Sony finally made the perfect
vlogging camera let's find out this is
the Sony GB one comes with a microphone
windscreen micro USB cable battery and
the camera and a flip-out screen a
checklist for the things that I have
been looking for in a vlogging camera
and this camera right here checks almost
every single one of those boxes I could
not be more excited to show this to you
guys today normally these little point
and shoot cameras are geared towards
photographers but this is one of the
first Sony cameras that I feel like they
really were thinking about video first
photo second this screen will also flip
the opposite way so you'll be able to
protect your screen when it's not in use
it has a 3.5 millimeter jack input for
audio a microUSB port and HDMI out it
uses the NP bx1 battery this is used in
a lot of the rx100 series so if you have
somebody batteries either in London
you guys are gonna witness my first vlog
that I'm gonna record and what I love
already about this is the record button
is right here where it should be where
you normally would take a photo there
are so many settings that we're gonna go
through in this camera but right now I
have it on the steady mode which gives
me a nice field of view another thing
that I'm loving so far is it has this
little a hot shoe mount it has a little
smaller they call them dead kittens it's
kind of a terrible thing that's to help
reduce wind noise and this also now has
a directional microphone facing forward
so that'll help if you are vlogging and
filming yourself that the microphone
will be able to pick you up and not
everything around you
I can't wait to test out all of these
features so I guess let's get started
vlogging backwards here we go
vlogging SteadyShot is off and now let's
turn it on we're now on steady shot
standard is it smooth this steady stable
just like me coming out of quarantine
here's our active SETI mode until it's
much more cropped in than the previous
two
what is it steadier I don't know you be
the judge well I'm gonna be the judge
cuz I'm gonna be watching the video and
processing feel steady oh my gosh
product showcase for unboxing and
showing products watch how quickly it
focuses Oh hold you want to see my phone
look at this Oh
focused holy bleep
[Music]
this is an optional vlogger kit that you
can get to go with your camera it comes
with this bluetooth tripod remote
control and an SD card this will allow
you to wirelessly connect to your camera
and control it you can take photos zoom
and start and stop recording this
connects to bluetooth so there's no
cables needed and it connects very
easily inside of the settings I also
like this because it is a little tiny
tripod it will allow you to easily
adjust your camera to get the right shot
one of these new settings that I'm
really excited to show you guys it's
called background G focus now in most
cameras you would just adjust the
aperture so that you can get that nice
blurred background well with this it's a
single button that will adjust the
aperture automatically to give you this
a nice blurred out bokeh background and
when I press it again it turns it off
and when I press it again turns it back
on and once again here's what it looks
like off and there's background defocus
on I can't focus right now because it's
so bright my eyes aren't opening I think
it looks really good so far I am
incredibly impressed with this camera
one of the things that a classic
iJustine video cannot live without is
slow-mo montages so this does also
include slow-mo but it also has super
slow-mo in the high frame rate options
so you can shoot up to 960 frames a
second so slow-mo montage let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
camera also has a bunch of different
color profiles so you can go into the
picture profile settings there's ten
that are currently programmed into here
so I'm gonna go through all of them and
show you guys what those look like and
show you some color grading options that
you can do with that the first one
attest is with no picture profiles on of
course the ND filter is on because it is
a little bit bright so let's let's do it
[Music]
and here they are all lined up next to
each others is every single option that
is built-in into the camera this is no
color grading and here is with color
grading I went in individually and
adjusted each one to the way that I
liked it this will allow you to have so
many more options when you're in post if
you do love color grading then
definitely do experiment with the
picture profiles
[Music]
okay the Sun is still out
I'm emerging from my quarantine cave of
editing I was so blown away by PP ten
he's actually shooting at hlg 2020 so it
was a different color profile that all
the previous ones would for rec.709 so
this is giving such a massive dynamic
range that i thought originally
oh no the footage is all overexposed but
in a no we have so much more range in
these highlights than any of the other
previous clips I'm really excited to
test out some of these color profiles as
you guys saw I did kind of line up each
and every single one of those and each
one I went and individually graded until
I thought it looked good I'm not the
best at color grading but I do love
about color grading is it as an art so
not everyone has the same taste when it
comes to what looks good as far as
coloring so to each their own but this
is this is cool I don't necessarily mess
around with a lot of the picture profile
settings because when I'm shooting on a
little point shoot camera like this I
normally just set everything to auto so
that I don't have to think about it and
my shot will just look good oh this this
gives us so many more options oh I'm so
excited
these are SAR monic wireless microphones
and what's great about these is you can
have the option of getting two
transmitters with one receiver so if my
sister and I are outside filming and
shooting we can only have this one
little receiver and both of us with our
stuff so fast we'll have these
transmitters on so I'll be able to pick
up both of our audio let's go back
outside and test this out hey Jen yeah
yeah
the focus it's so amazing
hey I'm posting a ticked-off do you know
I haven't posted in a couple months I've
been really bad me too because Animal
Crossing is basically taking over my
life same right now we're testing out
the harmonic blink microphone systems
these are pretty cool this is pretty
cool very convenient it's a look I'm
separating separating so you can still
hear us both equally
I'm not separating two parts as the dog
is an anchor what is he doing sitting oh
my god what my mask on I'm not around
any other people except Jenna but mask
up let's go making this videos made me
really miss vlogging a lot this camera
is incredible honestly it's just
everything works what's your favorite
features well obviously the screen but
also the multi interface - there's so
many things I love the product showcase
I love the yeah from the focus
backgrounds the batteries are the same
as the rx100 series which is nice yeah
same battery we're also shooting this
right now on the active steady shot so
this one crops in a little more bit
since I'm not actually holding the
camera it doesn't make that much of a
difference but if you are holding the
camera I would say just use a regular
study shot that way it won't be as
cropped in on your face but it's so
super steady how smooth is it move
smooth steady stable is this new feature
o.o smooth and steady bullet on the
house and i'm in the house boy no we're
not in the house you know this also
takes photos - really yeah I guess you
do need to take a thumbnail
oh it's windy it's gonna be a nice test
of this windshield windshield ha well
you know so we are working on our vlog
for this camera Jenna's also filming
hers while we're riding bikes Jenna was
testing out these stabilization modes on
here so I'm gonna steal a very small
clip of that demo Thank You Jenna it was
of you anyway so I'm gonna be using it's
really crazy because you have to wear a
mask of the beach you can't actually be
laying on the beach but people are still
disobeying and play on the beach anyway
this is a test of the skin smoothing
feature it's also windy so I'm gonna be
very interested to see how this works
out
so right now the skin filter is off
completely off this is my natural self
now let's fix it this is skin filter
setting of low and I took my mask off
for this it's kind of hard to test a
skin the smoothing feature with a mask
on
this is the medium how does it look do I
look like I am 12 years old now
this is skin smoothing setting hi I look
like I just have been brought into the
world
I am so fresh-faced and new it's like
hey mom I'm here beauty gurus take
notice mask up let's continue the video
there are a few things that I wish that
this camera had but I don't want to be
too greedy because this checks off
almost all of the boxes for what I was
looking for in a compact vlogging camera
one of the things that I wish that it
did have was an audio output so I'd be
able to moderate the audio I also wish
that it would charge via USB see and I
also wish that I could use a larger Sony
hot shoe adapter so that I could use XLR
microphones on this I do understand why
that doesn't work because those XLR
adapters are using the hot shoot and
it's powered by the camera if this did
work with that XLR adapter I feel like
that would kill the battery so quickly
so it definitely makes sense that's why
that doesn't work with us this camera is
still perfect so those are a few of the
minor complaints that I have I shouldn't
even be complaining because this camera
it's so incredible also while editing I
realized I didn't film an end to this
video so here it is the end to the video
I am in love with this camera it is
really really amazing and I cannot wait
to take it out test it out more on maybe
an adventure maybe not an adventure
maybe I'll just start using this camera
to shoot around the house for some of
the tech videos that I do my sister also
made a video about this camera and so
did Farouk I will put their video links
in the description because I know for a
fact that Farooq's video is going to be
incredible all of his camera reviews and
phone review videos are always just so
far above and beyond what almost anybody
else ever tests out it's super
impressive so I hope with both of their
links in the description box and with
that I'm gonna go back into my editing
cave and finish editing this video even
though for you guys it's over so I'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]